hi my name is Sebastian Bolton I'm one
of the frame of developers for the wall
from your netbook framework and my talk
will be about the novel frame of you
from the language where it's going where
it came from and also larger industry
trends and your networks
so my name is Sebastian Bernstein I'm
one of the two major developers on the
neural network framework in orphan
language and today's talk there's been a
lot of talks this whole week about yeah
applying your networks to images and
yeah they've been lots of talks with you
so I'm not going to go into mass of
details about learning how the framework
works or things like this I'm going to
focus more on higher-level pictures so
the first thing is I want to discuss a
bit in the last year what has happened
in your networks in the wider industry
and after that I want to give some
high-level ideas of sort of design
principles that we have that we follow
for the neural network framework in
orphan language and then also some
upcoming features so first of all your
networks have this last year have become
even more popular than the year before
that and they've now become
productionize in many places so for
example from which machine translation
in the past google has had very
customized and handwritten sort of
pipeline for translating different
languages and they came to the
conclusion that they couldn't prove it
anymore and they continuously though had
issues of the neural networks that they
couldn't deploy cheaply enough that was
the main problem but last year with some
new hardware they finally gotten it that
it's cheap enough to actually deploy
feasibly and yeah and so when this came
online last year for example like the
number one training Twitter topic on
Google and Japanese Twitter above some
cult anime series and some long-awaited
new single from a goal Idol supergroup
everyone wondered how had Google
Translate become so unkindly artful so
and the reason for that was because
they've switched in neural networks
other kinds of things out of the
highlights so things like I'll forego so
neural networks are one of the key
pieces and the the architecture for both
ago they sort of evaluates how good they
think a position is
and that can prune down the search space
massively so this was this was last year
and even like a few days ago I think it
was yesterday this was announced that
deepmind had gotten major improvements
previously it was trained pre trained on
human games but now this new version is
completely untrained on human games it
learns completely by itself and it's
yeah it's yellow rating has vastly
higher than the one that beats least at
all okay so other kinds of things
there's a lot of applications to
robotics so for example this is from
open AI they have a nice little demo a
human can teach the robot to do
something within VR and the neural
network has to learn how to imitate that
so it's a way of very quickly teaching
robots what to do and yeah neural
networks are very important for this
this as well this architecture okay and
other kinds of things are from medical
imaging this was the front cover of
nature lesions Luntz this was basically
finding that you can have dermatologists
level classification of skin disorders
with just a picture and this is the case
across medical imaging that newer
networks are becoming as good as doctors
at yeah as a diagnosing things so this
is just a whole slew of applications
that have come out from the important
pieces of self-driving cars - speech
recognition almost every system uses
that natural language processing from
question-answering to deposit sorry the
somehow weirdly came out here this is e
it looks a bit different if you don't go
into the mode
so from sentiment analysis and then also
physics things like there's a talk I
think later on about using this form I
go for detecting gravitational waves
again you have massive amounts of data
from detectors and you need to make
sense of it and Finance is also
obviously like image processing there's
hundreds of applications so what's
happened is that
the consequence of this widespread
application is that there's become
companies have made specialized hardware
so the race to make hardware that all
the difference
AI sort of application people want has
heated up massively so NVIDIA has a
special chip called the Volta v100 this
has specialized tensor cores that give
ya a peak performance of 120 teraflops
and we're gonna support this in eleven
point three this upcoming V 100 we're
actually getting out on one soon to be
able to test out on and then Google has
obviously they've got tens of processing
units and Intel has a new chip that came
out a few days ago but no one yeah we
can't you can't get access to it yes
okay so this is one major thing so
hardware a lot of specialized hardware's
come out and the second thing is that
there's been huge investment in
frameworks so Nvidia for example has
highly optimized new network primitives
called CUDA ninh Intel came out to the
game as well now with their own
optimized primitives which are still in
the beta phase we're gonna support these
as soon as they're ready but they still
quite buggy so this should speed up our
CPU evaluation and training on for
neural networks for convolutional neural
networks by about a factor of 10 so this
will be a very nice speed-up once we get
that and then framework wise it's become
a huge undertaking to build these
frameworks so the the major corporations
like Microsoft they have CNT K Google
has tensorflow Facebook has high torture
cafe to which they maintain and they
they have a huge number of developers on
that and there's also an X naught which
we are using and this is the only real
major framework that is still alive so
certain frameworks like theano or so
we're not backed by a major corporation
but they've died now so the only one
surviving is MX nurse and it's actually
it's it's part of the Apache foundation
and it's supported by lots of companies
so we also provide development supports
and yeah like Amazon is one of the major
companies
supports it in video etc so one more
thing with a mixed nut is that one of
them sort of major advantages that we
have in our framework is that any
anything that's yeah all the benefits
that MX net gets from its four hundred
contributors and also the major
corporations that's that's sort of our
building it we automatically pass down
to our users without any effort so it's
been a very nice collaboration with them
and also yeah we support now exporting
to to MX not so there's no lock-in
anymore so if you want have a network
you can easily export to MX net or
import it from a next note and maybe
just mention this very quickly but MX
net is also building a compiler stack so
that you can compile neural networks for
any sort of device this may be a bit
small needs make it bigger so whether
you want to compile it to are more x86
or Java scripts this sort of support is
coming at some point and the last thing
is that it's the official framework for
Amazon Web Services so Amazon has spent
huge amount of money improving MX net to
run efficiently on ec2 and we're in the
process of making it easier for users
and ourselves to train on ec2 so this is
something that you can hope you look
forward to soon okay so the second sort
of thing they don't discuss is one is in
the industries trends but the second
thing is what sort of motivate where how
is our framework gonna evolve in the
next year or two and to understand how
it's going and the sort of motivations
for the things we're doing you have to
understand the sort of larger scale
visions that we have for this framework
and what we want it to be for so lots of
functionality in Mathematica is is maybe
a few users that want to use it and the
way you implement things it depends yeah
it's related to how what yeah who's
going to be consuming this functionality
so the first thing is that one of the
major consumers of this functionality is
now internal groups in Wolfram
so they made a machine learning group
and the image processing group we have a
list of maybe like 50 different
top-level functions that we want to use
neural networks for that currently we
cannot do from things like speech
recognition to question answering to
image colorization to image description
generation image question answering
there's many many of these functions and
we want to build this or we're currently
building this with the framework so a
lot of the design that you might see and
we add layers that pop up in the
framework they are because there are
requirements for our internal usage so
things again mean simple things that
already there things like image identify
to do is busy working on image contents
which gives you like bounding boxes of
all the objects and image and yeah and
Timothy is going to work on speech
recognition so we're gonna have a whole
slew of application let's that's need
this framework to be fast enough for
very large-scale training the second
vision is that we want to make
pre-trained networks a first-class
citizen of the language so it's actually
very hard to train these networks so you
need huge amounts of data so for some of
these in the repository that we've got
now there's like maybe a hundred million
images that they've got that we use to
train them all so the computation is not
trivial it requires sometimes multiple
GPUs the train for sometimes a month
like for speech recognition and most
users just don't have that so one of the
sort of major pieces is the network
repository that a few people have worked
on and basically this repository is
first even showed that's already at the
keynote but it gives you access to a
growing number of of networks from
things like image restart restart Anor
maybe something like colorization where
you give it a black-and-white image and
the network can colorize it example so
and we have very nice documentation for
these networks we can show them off and
you can easy downloads for example this
this notebook either in the cloud or
just download the notebook so this is
going to be a growing collection and
these are all accessible via net model
so in the in the SIS in the language you
can just say net model get me the model
here's nets and in this case it wants to
find key points of the of the face so it
finds who the eyes are the nose and the
mouth so and yeah these models the range
some of them are strange like maybe you
know the finds not-safe-for-work
detection images are not safe work or
finding like the geolocation of
something or finding how many objects
there are an image in this case it says
okay there's two major objects and image
so this collection is going to get I
don't know maybe a hundred networks or
larger at some point so the other thing
is that's they're also just very hard to
define yourself these networks so huge
amounts of effort have been expended to
find the best architectures for neural
networks and you just cannot reinvent
the wheel so for images things like
ResNet are just very effective and you
almost always want to use that and if
you look at this architecture each of
these is an aircraft inside here and
this is like a chain of like a hundred
or something of these if you're gonna
write this out yourself it's very messy
and ugly so it's very powerful to have
these things available and what we're
sort of moving towards is this high
level paradigm that's it's very
difficult to write yeah like an image a
good image recognition network right now
what you really want to do is use
premades components and you will just
want to put them together you want to
cut things off them and then just stick
them in where you want them so if you
haven't an image coming into the network
you wanna say okay ResNet is good for
image
present it there okay we want to now
generate some description okay we have a
language model that's we can plug on top
of that so there's like a a much higher
level paradigm that we wanted to
introduce once we have a good collection
of these networks and also what's cool
is that because that was symbolic in
Mathematica these networks you can do
all kinds of operations like take things
or take parts etc etc okay so this is
the second sort of vision that we're
sort of moving towards and one of the
things that we need for this vision is
also to train these things ourselves
again the last thing is that we want to
make this framework as simple as
possible especially compared to other
frameworks out there so one basic thing
is that we have a type system so in this
case we you know we string together some
network and it infers it knows okay this
is an embedding layer and this requires
a vector of well I've told what the
input of entire chain is but it infers
exactly that this is a vector of size
two of indices in the range of one to
four and it does shape and Ferns through
the network and type inference as well
and this is a feature that is really
nice and it allows things like very
simple error messages so for example in
this case I've given integers 1 & 6 but
of course it's expecting integers
between 1 & 4 and it tells you this and
if you use other frameworks like Kerris
and whatnot there are very cryptic error
messages that you get if you make even
slight mistakes the second sort of major
principle that we've decided on that
makes it quite different from other
frameworks is this idea of encoders and
decoders so that is that you can attach
a special pre-processing unit at the
beginning in this case there's an image
preprocessor and image processor it
conforms the image it puts it in the
right color space it removes the Alpha
Channel
it might remove the mean image all these
sorts of things these details that most
frameworks have in separate scripts we
do this in one inside the network and
the same with the output often you want
to output a class you don't just want to
have like a vector coming out of the
thing
and this makes it very fun to use
because we can have a single network
that we can export and things like the
classes live with the network if you
want to see it what what other sort of
frameworks look like you can maybe okay
maybe I won't show this entirely you can
look at this yourself but this is to
make a single prediction well you have
to get find the different scripts
interpolation types for the resizing of
the images you know where's where the
scripts living where's the mean image
living you transpose the image to get
them to BGR order and then finally you
can do some classification but of course
the classes are no different scripts you
have to do some processing yay finally
we have that it's a tabby cat so this is
like this is the official example from
cafe for example so this whole thing
makes it very simple and the last thing
that we've are quite different from
other frameworks is that we have
first-class variable length sequence
support so it's actually very hard for
neural network frameworks to deal with
variable length sequences because you
always want to batch together examples
so on modern GPUs it's vastly more
efficient if you can have batches of
examples that go together but if you're
doing things like matrix multiplication
you can't have ragged arrays so other
frameworks require all kinds of things
from bucket from padding the sequences
for the same length doing a bucketing
procedure so that sequences that are
similar get trained together and then
you can use single operation like matrix
multiplication operations on them but
for us we've decided that we're going to
put in a lot of work and make it a much
more complicated to implement but we
have native support for the full
variable length so for example in this
case you know some strings this is of
length 4 okay these are all of length 4
okay like this one length this is a
different length from this one like 5
and this one is a 4 so this is a very
simple task you have a string and you
just want to predict what the number is
inside the string given the string
so you get a sequence of characters and
you want to say okay given the sequence
of characters what did it add up to so
for us it's very simple you just have a
simple net and you can see inside here
that these are completely these a
variable length so they can take in
sequences of any size and you can just
train it okay this always gets messed up
unfortunately for presentation mode much
away okay I won't let it go all the way
it's maybe a bit of a waste of time but
okay it's praiseful bad enough that it
won't work okay somewhat reasonable not
super good but if you let it rain a bit
longer it will work so super simple so
other kinds of things like you can make
your own it's extensible this whole
system so we have support for defining
your own recurrent operators so people
who want to do research in this and they
want to try out different architectures
all of this just automatically works out
the box and you can define with a net
fold operator you can say okay here's a
quote little piece and we want to fold
this across a sequence and we want to
make this work on varying sequences
efficiently on GPUs on anything and it
just works and this is one of things
have been moving towards as well like
these sort of high level operators that
take other layers and do sort of
transformations alone okay so those are
the three major principles and stopping
on this I want to give a quick roadmap
about where sort of where we're going so
in the first version we basically had
simple recurrence and convolutional
networks we didn't have any iron ends we
did support GPU training and we had a
very limited set of layers so in 11.2
our task has already been to add
functionality the major thing was to add
recurrent Network support with variable
length sequence support and also
something like 32 new layers that we
added in those two versions and there's
been massive numbers of small
improvements from like a multi-threaded
image loader so that image
training as fast enough if you're doing
it out of call to things like an MX net
important exporter okay so the upcoming
roadmap again remembering that's one of
the major things that we need is for
internal training and that sort of
drives the things that we want so one of
the major features that people will I
think enjoy a lot is net function so
first of all a lot of net store fit into
a static graph so they have
contingencies inside the computation
graph so it might depend on data so
here's a simple example you do a you
have a convolution layer and you do a
computation if the max of the inputs is
greater than two then do something
otherwise do the convolution so this
sort of program at the moments you can't
build that at all because it's yeah like
in a net graph how would you build
something like this
you can't put if statements in but for
NLP especially if we're national
language processing it's becoming more
apparent that this is a good paradigm
for lots of topologies so things like pi
torch and china they basically only have
the support they only do dynamic graphs
so you write a program and you can
differentiate the program and also
things like okay so there's one big
piece that we counted I make graphs at
the moment the second thing is that we
can't do weight sharing very easily so
things like you know you want to use to
find a convolution layer and then use it
twice or three times or whatever in the
computation that's a bit hard as well
and this allows this and also a lot of
nets it's very hard to write them as net
graphs it's much more natural to have
variables and then use them in a program
so net function is going to solve all
these together it's going to have
dynamic evaluation so you can actually
have if statements or while loops or do
loops or anything else and you can
differentiate this entire program and
yes it will become a quite a general
auto grad engine that you can use for
many other kinds of things that you want
to differentiate not just neural
networks
and we also want to add things that
customly is once the compiler comes
online you know you can compile to LVM
and then eventually you can compile LLVM
to cuda this is something that
internally we want a lot because yeah
you often want to have custom layers and
for import/export we want to have
there's a new format that is sort of
common across many platforms it's
supported natively by three prep three
eight moments but probably a lot of
other frameworks were added as well
probably MX 10 as well and things like
performance enhancing was like multi-gpu
supports and for audio we don't
currently have good audio support we
don't have an audio encoder we're
getting that the image group has helped
us a lot to write this so there's a
whole bunch of things that we're getting
maybe I'll just very quickly mentioned
this last stuff as well a key piece of
frameworks is that training has to be
easy so internally we're working on
tools to make our own internal training
easy by deploying training on ec2 with
automatic reporting of losses and all
that to a central server and yeah and
this sort of interesting infrastructure
we want to make available to others as
well ok cool I think that's basically I
don't have to go through the conclusion